menschen die an verschwörungstheorien
glauben lassen sich in vier kategorien
einteilen
donald trump ein hätten jäger ist und
wieso das den usa und auch der
weltgemeinschaft erheblichen schaden
zufügt jetzt entwicklung 270 erquickung
ganz ehrlich mir macht das angst wir
leben in einem zeitalter in dem
verschwörungs theorien wahnsinnig
populär sind der grund es ist viel
einfacher an theorien mit einfachen
zusammenhängen zu glauben wie gut gegen
böse als zu verstehen dass die welt
leider ziemlich kompliziert ist und das
liegt in der natur des menschen es ist
aus einer umwelt gewohnt relativ
einfache sachverhalte vorzufinden sein
glas zersplittert
ein zerbrochenes glas liegt auf der erde
erbringt alkohol getrunken er malt mit
pinsel und farbe der untergrund färbt
sich entsprechend in größeren
zusammenhängen funktioniert das aber
einfach nicht mehr
entscheidungsprozesse finden sich
konkurrent die physik ist mit
quantentheorie und relativitätstheorie
so komplex dass die folge für die
wirklichkeit kaum nachvollziehbar sind
wie können wir zum beispiel verstehen
dass die gravitation ein phänomen das
durch die allgemeine relativitätstheorie
erklärt wird und keine kraft sondern die
krümmung von raum und zeit ist deshalb
den verschwörungstheorien bei komplexen
themen wie zum beispiel den klimawandel
sieht aus wie blei als die wirklichkeit
und durch das internet können sich viel
leichter verbreiten was thema so
schwierig macht manchmal sind
verschwörungstheorien nur schwer von der
realität unterscheidbar werden wir alle
überwacht etwas noten hat s aufgeklärt
und das ist wahrlich keine
verschwörungstheorien oder worte geht
niemand hätte gedacht dass der
amtierende us-präsident zu einer von ihm
gesteuerten abhöraktion fähig wäre oder
ihr hat obama tram bespitzeln lassen
hier kann man allerdings den nachrichten
verlauf von berechtigten und unabhängig
geführten untersuchung des fbi bis zu
den white bad news verfolgen und
feststellen dass kommt sich darauf
beziehen aber was genau ist unser
heutiges problem wichtige politiker
glauben an verschwörungstheorien oder
die mehrheit der wähler beim exit und
treffen vor allem für ihr eigenes land
verheerende entscheidungen aber wer
glaubt an verschwörungstheorien vier
typen von verschwörungstheoretikern der
mediziner thomas grüter hat ein buch
darüber geschrieben freimaurer
illuminaten und andere verschwörer er
unterscheidet gruppen nummer 1
der besetzer aufklärer er hat etwas
entdeckt und will die welt unbedingt
über diese theorie informieren das wäre
so als würde ich der kein
wissenschaftler ist an der theorie
festhalten dass die dunkle materie aus
schwarzen löchern besteht auch wenn es
dann irgendwann zahlreiche gegenbeweise
geben sollte ich bin von dieser theorie
überzeugt aber wenn es andere beweise
gibt muss ich sie halt aufgeben das ist
bei verschwörungstheoretiker nicht der
fall sie bleiben dabei nummer zwei der
zeichen deutscher er kennt die großen
zusammenhänge vermeintlich und weiß wer
zu den bösen in der welt gehört alles
was passiert ordnet er in dieses
grundmuster ein zum beispiel die
illuminati herrschen über die welt und
stecken hinter allem nummer drei
psychisch kranke
sie fühlen sich persönlich verfolgt und
deuten zahlreiche ereignisse als auch
nie gerechnet um nummer vier hexenjäger
wie donald trump sie haben die
verschwörer nicht nur entdeckt oder
verfolgen sie
berühmte beispiele sind heinrich kramer
tatsächlicher hektar im mittelalter oder
joseph mccarthy der in den usa in den
fünfzigerjahren kommunisten gejagt hat
beides man natürlich absoluter quatsch
und jetzt ist er verbannt menschen aus
bestimmten ländern weil sie muslime sind
oder rwe
die mexikanischen einwanderer wieder
loswerden beziehungsweise sie gar nicht
erst ins land lassen er behauptet dass
obama ihn bespitzelt hat mit dem land
schlecht geht und so weiter das problem
ist dafür gibt es natürlich auch für
alle gründe vielen branchen gegen
schlecht es gibt also einen realen
hintergrund doch seine rückschlüsse wie
40 prozent arbeitslosigkeit sind
natürlich absolut nicht wahr das problem
ist er entscheidet über die politik die
sich damit auf verschwörungstheorien
die konsequenz wird sein dass sie am
laufenden band falsche entscheidung
getroffen werden und diese entscheidung
werden die usa in eine ernsthafte krise
führen und damit auch die
weltgemeinschaft verletzt haben
fachleute kalkuliert dass die einführung
von 15 zur vernichtung von
arbeitsplätzen führen wird es wird also
das gegenteil von dem erreicht was
eigentlich erreicht werden soll
stattdessen wird in den usa eine
hexenjagd gegenüber minderheiten
gestartet in dem land weiter schaden
wird es kommen muss schlechten zeiten
auch die usa und damit auf die ganze
welt zu und nur weil ein politiker
lieber einfach strukturierten
verschwörungstheorien glauben will als
zu akzeptieren dass die welt in
wirklichkeit kompliziert ist wenn ihr
blick zum abonnieren wollt dann wird mir
hier ein abo aufsaugen vergesst nicht
wir einen auf die glocke zu geben hier
geht es zu einer fest auf liste von flix
ich sag jetzt mal bestand platz ab